Le exactly
dress yeah
the something
that's
real morning how are
you
good okay folks we are
today we're going to we're pretty much
done with the mechanics of discounted
cash flow
valuation how to estimate cash flows
discount rates growth rates terminal
value if you notice none of the things
are particularly complicated just coming
together of all those
pieces today we're going to talk about
what I call the loose sense and
valuation things we do after we claim
we're done so I'm going to start today's
session the start of the class test by
focusing on some of those issues
right you take your free cash flow to
the firm you discounted the cost of
capital you get a value for the
operating assets then what are we taught
to do in every book at cash right so I'm
going to start with a question about
cash because I want to take a deeper
look at cash
today and I'm going to look at something
I've heard from equity research analyst
and you tell me whether you can go along
with this lots of companies are big cash
balances 10 billion 50 billion 150
billion 200 100
billion and I've heard analyst said that
what's the problem with cash balances is
the rate of return they earn is much
lower than a company's cost of
capital I thought we said that metric
right if a company doesn't earn its cost
of capital it's destroying value does
the statement hold is it true that cash
is a wasting asset because it earns a
return less than your cost of capital
you take if it's invested it's invested
I mean let's take apple apple right now
makes 4% on its cash its cost of capital
is 9% it makes 35% of its projects does
it make cash a wasting asset for app no
why not because it has a return of 4%
and why is that enough uh because the
earnings that they have plus uh their
Investments with their cash is larger
than their cost of capital do we even
need to go there what's a cash invested
in something liquid and riskless right
if you or I invested something liquid or
riskless which I had to do yesterday I
to sweep all the extra cash in my
brokerage account into something so it's
not sitting around idle I bought TBL why
because you know you can directly Au you
don't have to go through a money market
fund you can buy the TBL directly you
know what I earn roughly
4% it's true cash earns a low rate of
return but it's a rate of return that
you should earn given on something
liquid and riskless we'll talk about
reasons to punish a company for holding
cash but it should never be you earn a
low rate of return if we did that think
of the damage we could do going around
companies and saying I'm going to take
off 10% off your cash or 15% so the low
rate of return doesn't bother me but the
fact that you could do other things with
the cash potentially could be a problem
France you look like you have a
question take a second issue and this I
think is to me the biggest challenge in
discounted cash flow valuation you value
a company you take cash flows discount
at the cost of capital you deal with
cash and then you look around you
realize your company has cross Holdings
so I want to start by testing your
accounting of how cross Holdings get
dealt with if you feel comfortable
enough jump in if not I'll fill in the
gaps let's assume of have a company
company a owns 60% of Company B and
you're looking at company A's financial
statements so you take the revenues
earnings exactly the way we've done free
cash flow to the firm how much of
Company B will be in your value do you
see what my question is you've taken the
revenues earnings cash flows from
company a it own 60% Michael tell me
why accounting rules required to
consolidate I've never understood this
so I own 60% you ask ask me to act like
I Own 100% do you see what this is going
to create at the end right after I
finish the valuation I have a 40% %
problem so what do I have to do I have
to clean up for that 40% we talk about
how you know many analysts do it and why
it might not be
complete let's take another exercise
let's suppose company a owns 10% of
Company B Michael I'm going to come back
to you now what will I see in the
financial statements
huh it's right on
the right on the control side so anytime
you're not consolidating where does the
number show up
below the operating income line which
means when I do my free cash flow to the
firm I'm going to completely miss it
which means I have a lot of mopping up
to do you're valuing
Microsoft I don't think your open AI
position is Consolidated that's a big
chunk you're leaving on the table
because it's not Consolidated so already
you can see with cross Holdings why this
is going to be messy right sometimes you
overcount sometimes you don't count it
all and you got to bring it all
in so let's say you've done with cash
you've dealt with cross Holdings and you
take a look at the accounting balance
sheet and you get tempted tempted to do
what to start adding other stuff on
that's on the balance
sheet so I'm going to go through a list
of things and you tell me whether if
you've done a discounted cash flow
valuation you would add these items on
and if you will tell me why if not tell
me why not first the company has a
headquarters Building New York City
worth hundreds of millions of dollarss
would you add on the value so let's say
value JP Morgan right 277 Park 270 Park
I mean you can go around the city all
those buildings if you add them up
collectively worth more than a billion
dollars would you add on the value of
the headquarters
burden is it a valuable asset
yeah but who's sitting in those
buildings Traders and bankers what do
they do hopefully
something but they generate the cash
flows used to Value do you see where I'm
going right when you value the cash
flows you can't value the things that
generate those cash flows as well so I'm
not going to count the headquarters
building because it's already in my cash
flows what about vacant land I don't
know whe this any vacant land maybe in
the East Village somewhere drug dealers
have
filled would you add that
on what do you say what
as long as I have not counted as
something I'm going to build a factory
on four years from now and have cash
flows you see what the test always is
have I somehow counted the benefit what
about patterns if you're a
pharmaceutical
company why not
with I think you already have the
pattern here right whenever you look at
an item say is it already in the cash
flows and the answer is yes you can't
eat your cake can have it
too let's go to the easy ones how about
brand name accountants are increasingly
putting it on accounting balance sheets
right why
not benefits out of it so it's already
part of your and tell me where right
because the brand name people where is
it and you got to be very specific where
is it showing
up I take
Coca-Cola everywhere right revenues
margins even the rate at which I can
borrow at I've counted it in you can
argue maybe I can use it but it's
already in there let's not even talk
about good that's a
nonstarter what if your poo has gone on
a on this Bene of collecting picassos
using company
money then maybe right first figuring
out what he owns and then you know so if
he owns a penthouse apartment on Fifth
Avenue these are you know these these
kind of add-on assets that old companies
accumulate technically you could argue
that they should be counted but the
question is how will you ever get your
hands on them so the general rule is be
careful about what you add on because
most of the time it's already in your
cash
flows one final Point some of you are
valuing companies that are going to be
easy to Value easy because the the
accounting is straightforward you know
what they do some of you are working
with companies that are messy messy in
many ways the accounting is messy the
business mix is Mex messy that special
purpose
entities which of the two companies
assuming the numbers look pretty similar
which of the two companies would you
value more highly the simpler company or
the more complex company or they both
have let's say the all of the numbers
look exactly the
same M you want to try simpler company
more complex
company I think they should be in fact
you open up any textbook they should be
value the same but go with your got here
would you really value this the
say
yes complect slow mobility in a complex
there are so many words in there that I
want to kind of take them on at a time
cash flow mobility in what sense the
cash flow in a complex structure if the
cash majority of the cash is sitting at
let's say a subsidary that's not easily
accessible then I think it's more
difficult to
okay I I see where you're going in terms
of can I get my hands on the cash flows
it looks like it there like it's there
that could be part of it what else what
try B will be more value that's an
interesting twist so you know we have
one simple company one complex company
I'll give you the reason why in
valuation theory and practice we ignore
complexity we make a very dangerous
assumption we make the assumption that
what you don't know will get averaged
out that's a basis of diversification
right but let's step back and think
about it right think about complex
companies that are things you don't know
what are the things you don't know what
management has chose and not to tell you
ask you a follow question what do
managers hold back on good news or bad
news news right the problem with the
diversification argument here with
complex companies when you get surprises
they're more likely to be when was the
last time you woke up to an accounting
surprise that said you you know what
guys we made five times more money than
you thought we did right the surprises
are one-sided it's a you know I'll talk
about when I started thinking about this
actively and how we might have to bring
it into value so already you can see
lots of different strands so let's go
back to the lecture notes and start
with cash
you know how Academia Works any of you
have friends or acquaintances who are
professors who complain about how hard
their lives are don't believe them I'll
tell you how how hard I work I to teach
like six hours a week for 15 weeks I get
the remaining 37 weeks
off but because I work so hard every
year every seventh year I get the entire
year off with pay it's called a
sabatical it's very biblical I work for
six years years get the seventh year off
I'm sure you all will have similar
Arrangements at your work work 15 weeks
get 37 weeks off my wife teaches fifth
grade she said you have a cushy life and
I said of course I
do so every seventh year you get a
sabatical and usually people have big
plans for their
sabatical
so this was two sabatical ago in
Academia you measure your life in
sabatical to
sabatical so there's about two sabatical
ago sabatical coming up and my plan for
my sabatical was I wanted to wake up
every day with nothing to do for a whole
year the first day of my sabatical I was
a little over the top about this I went
to an office supply store and go one of
those things where you write to-do list
and I put it up so I stayed at home put
it up above the little section of my
home where I used to work and my four
kids were all at home then and they were
going to school they came down to go to
school and I pointed to my to-do list
nothing to do today kids pissed them off
no end but then they left and then I
made my fatal mistake my wife came down
the stairs and I said Han I have nothing
to do today she said really why don't
you take the dog for a walk I took the
dog for a walk I come back there's an
item on my to-do list says pick up bok
choy at the grocery store I'll make a
confession I had no idea what bok choy
was I was too embarrassed to ask an hour
and a half the grocer store I finally
find it's ugly looking
cabbage I come back home another item on
my to-do list pick up kids from school
and after the fourth or the fifth item I
said I need to find things to do to keep
my wife off my list desperately so I get
an email from the editor of CFA magazine
a magazine I've never read in my
life he says would you write an article
for us my first reaction was I'm in a
sabatical I want nothing to do but then
I realized I needed things to do so I
said okay and I tell you the only thing
I've ever written in my life that's got
me hate mail you know how difficult it
is to get hate mail in finance people
don't feel strongly enough to hate you
for using bottomup Bas or implied Equity
risk
premiums one reason I got the hate mail
was the title for the for the piece it
said stop the
garnishing you know what I was talking
about the practice and valuation you
tell me you're done the add 30% for
control knock off 25% for liquidity add
15 % subtract 10% so if you're going to
do this you're going to come back to
whatever number you wanted to see in the
first place and I might have used the
word arbitrary to describe the premiums
and discounts which I think piss people
off so wave of insults come in mostly
from private company
appraises but one of them I think got a
got a got a good point they said if you
don't like the way we're doing things in
valuation why don't you talk about how
to do them better and I said you have a
point I I have 11 months left in my
sabatical each month I'm going to pick
up a loose head and I'm going to talk
about how I would try to approach Val
the lose side the first month was on
cash second month on control third month
on liquidity so my plans to do
absolutely nothing on my sabatical fell
to Pieces but it's now one half of one
of my books demod valuation the second
half of the book is the residue of that
sabatical so I'm going to take you on a
speedy journey through that sabatical
year and talk about some of the loose s
I'm going to start with cash we already
talked about reasons not to discount
cash right don't discount cash because
it earns a low rate of return but I'm
going to argue that there might be some
companies where you see a cash balance
but you discount the cash balance and
other companies you see a cash balance
and attach a premium to it will talk
about what might lead you to do that
second stop cross Holdings in a perfect
world where I gave you access to all of
the information you wanted how would you
cross Holdings we we'll start with that
then we'll talk about the world we live
in and the limits we have on information
and why you might have to take shortcuts
or approximations to deal with cross
Holdings third stop I want to talk about
what else should I be counting off a
balance sheet what exactly is an add-on
asset because I've seen people take
things off the balance sheet add them
onto a DCF valuation and double count
and trible
count we'll make a stop at
complexity should I punish comp
companies for being
complex and then we'll talk about debt
we've already talked about debt in one
context right when we talked about cost
of capital but now this is a different
revisiting of that number we're saying
what should I be subtracting out from
the value of a firm to come up with
value of equity and I'm going to argue
that maybe the rules have to get little
looser because things you've got to
bring in that you worry about what if
there's a lawsuit hanging over your
company's head it might not be showing
up as a liability yet because it's just
brewing but should you be factoring that
in once you get to the value of
equity four 30 years ago I was teaching
this class the end was near right you
divide by the number of shares but
starting in the 1990s what did US
companies increasingly start to do in
terms of
compensation shifted options and then to
restricted stock there's a lot of
cleaning up to do that what if you have
options outstanding and I'm going to
argue the way in which we deal with
options and valuations Incredibly sloppy
trying to adjust the number of shares
fully diluted or count only the options
that are in the money so we'll talk
about how to deal with management
compensation in the form of options and
how it affects your value per share so
lot lots on the agenda let's start with
the value of cash the rule is very
simple right and this is thereare for a
reason don't mess with cash cash is Cash
100 million cash is worth a 100 million
and at least in firm value valuations
you keep it apart till the last moment
right you value the free cash flow
discounted the cost of capital you bring
it in at the last moment in equity
valuation it's actually unclear where it
shows up you do a dividend discount
model where does the cash up maybe it's
being used to pay the dividends but it's
kind of implicit free cash or Equity
model we start with net income without
adjusting for interest income basically
leave it in there cash is somewhere in
there you have no idea where so cash can
be very sloppy in the way we deal with
it so I'm going to start with a very
simple structure so we can see why cash
in the hands of different companies
might be valued different they have
three
companies they have same Enterprise
Value they have same cash balance and
these cash balances no doubt that there
is so this is not satum computer
cash you heard of that story an Indian
company that was a technology company
where the Auditors would go in and they
say we have 200 million in cash and say
where is the cash and the company said
well it's up there somewhere it's in
cyers space and there were a technology
company auditor said okay that must be
true turned out there no cash so there's
no doubt about this cash it's 100
million needs to the companies but
here's where they're different company a
has had a history of earning a return on
Capital roughly equal to its cost of
capital Company B has had a history of
earning a return on Capital that's less
than cost of capital all I can show you
is the history right I don't know what
they will do in the future company C has
had a history of earning 10% more than
its cost of capital the first two
companies are developed Market companies
the third company I put into
Argentina there's a reason I'm going to
bring that I'm going to argue that in
one of these three companies cash will
be a neutral asset in other words it'll
be valued exactly 100 million so let's
make a pause right there which of these
three companies is cash most likely to
be a neutral asset and why
other company and what is it about
company that makes it a neutral asset
it's a Blog company what do blog
companies do they don't hurt you they
don't help you they run in place before
you complain about a company being a
Blog company let's turn to the second
one which of these three companies is is
Cash most likely to be a wasting asset
and
why yes see is it the Orin Tina that
throws you up what is it about company C
that bothers you well that you know
returns um if it's return on invested
capitals higher than it's costed Capital
should be putting that cash to work
that's a different question they could
be worth even more but at least they
have good projects right yeah so with
company C I might say look why don't you
invest more and we can talk about why
they might not but their history
suggests they have good
products do you see why Company B
terrifies you or should terrify you what
is the have a history of
stupidity right you give stupid
management a lot of cash what do they do
even more stupid
things this might sound over the top but
if you have a history of taking bad
Investments doing terrible Acquisitions
and I see a cash balance I start
discounting it for the things you might
do with the cash it's not cash itself
that's a problem it's what I think you
might do with the cash Company B is most
likely to be the the one where you
discount the cash with company
C we'll talk about why the Argentina
might make a difference but I did regret
putting in Argentina because I did the
same session in Brazil a few years ago
to a person every person the audience
picked the third company I said why so
you can't trust these
argentines maybe they'd lost a soccer
game the previous week or something
there was something happening in under
the
surface but the reason I put on
Argentina is I'll go back to corporate
finance 101 the utopian world no company
needs a cash balance in that world you
know why because you have a great
project what do I assume you can do go
outad and raise the money Capital
markets are always open and accessible
so you don't need a cash balance now do
you see why I picked Argentina as my
country of origin in the in this Century
alone the AR Argentina as a country has
seen its entire Capital Market shut down
at least five times when I say shut down
you can't raise Equity can't borrow
money you have no access to Capital you
see the advantage of having a cash
balance in a market where Capital can
shut down you can survive the next
downturn you might even be able to buy
assets at Pennies on the dollar because
you have
cash cash might actually have a premium
not just because a company earns more
than its cost of capital Apple earns
more than its cost of capital I'm not
putting a premium on the 200 billion
cash because they can raise Capital if
they wanted to it's because they have
limited access to Capital that's why
when you see a small tech company with a
big cash balance before you jump down
their throat it might actually be a
sensible thing to do for them because
they can survive and deliver the growth
value that you think they're worth
rather than failing because they run out
of cash
are yeah that's that's different right
so if it's a young Growth Company you
might you might cut it some slack that's
true right
so so any questions on
that so the qu key issue then with cash
is not the cash itself is what whether
you can trust management of the cash if
you remember in corporate finance in the
dividend policy section I talked about
trust and how when you trust management
you're willing to let them hold the cash
and that trust comes from looking at
your history you have a history of doing
bad Acquisitions or taking terrible
Investments you lose that trust so the
right reason for discounting cash is
because you don't trust management the
wrong reason is Cash earns a low rate of
return that's kind of a
non-starter any questions on cash
balances so cash is an easy asset to
valuate you can even see even with cash
you might discount the
cash there's a set of companies whose
entire asset base is easy to Value
attach a number to called closed and
mutual
funds mutual funds typically open in
mutual fund so if you send your money to
T price of fidelity mellin what happens
the money comes in the number of units
increases your net asset value is
basically the total market value of the
fund divided by the number of ships in a
closon mutual fund you actually have a
publicly traded companies only assets
are other publicly traded companies they
buy apple and Washington Post and
whatever else and you buy shares in the
company you're saying this should be the
easiest of all companies to BU right the
shares in the company should be whatever
the value of the Holdings is divided by
the number of shares it's one of the in
in in corporate one more thing before I
leave the cash this is actually a you
know study from about 25 years ago which
looked at how much a dollar in cash is
valued in the hands of different
companies so it broke the entire US
market down study of just us companies
and it was a very clever study try to
actually isolate the cash balance of
what is the market attaching as a value
to cash cash I'll give you the good news
across all us companies a dollar in cash
is valued at a dollar why is that good
news because that's what we do in every
valuation but if you break companies
down into mature companies earning less
than the cost of cap companies like
company b a dollar in cash is valued at
69 that's an astonishing discount if you
think about it you have a $10 billion
cash balance I act as if you have only
6.9 billion and if you look at The Other
Extreme at smaller high growth firms
which earn well above the cost of
capital a dollar in cash is actually
valued at a122 the market seems to be
okay not just okay giving you a premium
because you hold on to
cash the first group The mature
companies which earned less than the
cost of capital it's a bit of a puzzle
right let's say I'm the manager of that
company and I come to you and you're my
advisor SL consultant I said look I'm
trading at a big discount of this big
cash balance how do I make the discount
go away what should your advice to me be
this very simple
advice give the cash back you know what
I'll fight you every step of the way why
because I want to hold the cash and
convince you that I've changed my
ways it's very so management sees the
discount but it doesn't want to take the
obvious
R now do you see why a call I can or a
bill acman this is your perfect
Target cuz you target The Firm all you
have to do is return the cash the
discount disappears you don't have to do
any operating shifts no leverage
changes without activist investors or
you can have companies hold big cash
balances have big discounts not much is
going to happen at those
companies so now let's talk about closed
in mutual funds in almost all of the
finance literature this is called a
puzzle we talk about why they called the
P they looked at closed in mutual funds
you'd expect them to trade it roughly
whatever their market value of their
Holdings is they consistently at least
on average there are a few exceptions
about 85% of them trade at a discount
the median discount is about 15% so
think about it you have a $100 million
in market cap stock publicly traded
stocks as your only assets I'm pricing
you at 85 million let's pause right
there does this look like a way you know
does it look like there's a pathway for
you to make Arbitrage profits in the
true sense of the word you can buy the
company for for 85 million right after
you liquidate the company sell the
publicly traded shares you should get
100 million back right so the first
puzzle was why doesn't that happen why
do you think that doesn't
happen you have a closed in fund with a
market cap of stocks of 100 million
trading at 85 million why don't you see
closed in funds that's being bought out
and liquidated
think through what will happen so buy
the closed in fund what's the first step
you have to be able to acquire the fund
without pushing the price up from 85
million to 100 million right Michael
maybe if the fund was liquidated the
Arbitrage would actually go away because
it would it would suppress you that's
extension the first one right you push
the price up but you still will gain on
that first section as you push the price
up right the average price should be
less than 100 million you also once you
get to 51% of the shares you have to be
able to liquidate the fund which means
that there's got to be a board of
directors that goes along many of these
funds are often headquartered in parts
of the world you can't actually get them
liquidated and there's a third problem
when you sell the shares and you get 100
million do you get to keep the entire
100 million there capital gains taxes so
there's lots of reasons they survive but
there is this enduring discount of 15%
so I want to First Look at why there's a
discount because I think that our
discussion of why cash might be
discounted gives us an opening for why
closed in funds are discounted let's say
you're r a closed in fund you make about
11% return you expect to make 11% return
but let's say given your risk you should
be making 11 and a half% you're earning
a half a percent less than you should am
I being unfair to you remember the
average active money manager
underperform the market by 1 to one and
a half% so I'm actually putting you in
the top third of money
managers but think of what will happen
now when I value your fund right you
invest $100 in your fund you make $1
each year you need to make 115% if I
value that fund it's basically a perpetu
forget about growth it's $1 divided by
0.115 which gives me like $96 for the
fund there's your 3% discount you put
growth on top of it it'll become a 10%
discount if I make you returns 10 and a
half% of 11 and a half% the discount is
going to get even worse do you see where
I'm going with this right if you're a
closed in fund manager the less I think
about you as a as a fund manager the
bigger the discount is going to
get now what about the 15% of closed in
funds that had trade at a
premium what does that tell you about
these
funds that you think that the managers
there will beat the market either
because they funds investing in
countries where these people have insert
information they can export the fund
manager has this great reput a so let's
talk about the most famous closon Fund
in history you probably never seen it
talked about as a closon fund It's
actually an insurance company that has a
close every insurance company has a
close and mutual fund inside it right
because why because insurance companies
collect premiums from you and I they
invest those premiums at least a fund
manager in whatever they
want I've given you enough Clues who am
I talking
about Berkshire had way with Geico being
the insurance front and Warren Buffett
being the manager of the closon fund you
have the most famous and best regarded
portfolio manager of all time running
your closed in fund how is it going to
show up it's going to show up as a
premium that I'm willing to pay for
busher haway one thing to remember when
you buy busher haway you're buying all
the shares that buer hatway invest in
Coca-Cola Washington Post you know
ocidental but you're paying a 50% pre
premum over the market price in doing so
CU that's effectively what that price to
book ratios remember that bway is
required to Mark to Market all its
Holdings you're paying a premium on top
of that so what I have in this graph
essentially is the market cap that's a
red line the book value of common equity
for the longest time the Burkshire haway
reports that Warren Buffett turned out
had a market cap number and a book value
number they've stopped doing it for the
last few years which tells you something
about the loss of faith even at busher
haway in Book value but I've also
graphed out what the price to book
ratios are for busher hatway which is
the typical insurance company you go
back to the 1993 2002 buer haway traded
a 30% premium you go to 2003 to 2012
about a 39% premium that premium dropped
off in the last decade and it's now
completely
gone why
I'm
sorry it's a kind of morbid thought I
don't know whether he's going to die
soon but he's 93 years old and he has
actually officially told the world that
he's not the one picking stocks I don't
know why people don't listen to him 10
years ago he picked Ted W Wexler and to
Kum to basically two portfolio managers
that he handpicked and he said look I'm
83 at that point 83 years old I'm not
going to be picking stocks these two
guys are picking stocks for you and
they're nice people they're good portfol
but they're not warrant Buffet the
buffet premium has faded because he is
older the market has factored that in
something to think about anytime you
have a fund driven by a superstar
manager this two shall pass and when you
pay a big premium for that fund you're
effectively going to see that premium
faade
away so as you look at closed in funds
you look at Cash the question asking is
who's running who's man investing this
money do I think they can earn more than
the market roughly the market or below
the
market you a question
yeah that's a they've never invested in
tech companies and we gave them a
premium 30 years ago right so that's a
different issue almost they were able to
make money but I think the fact that you
don't have a stock picker that is as
highly regarded probably never will as
Warren Buffett is a big factor in the
fading of the
pris so let's talk about cross Holdings
first step in dealing with cross
Holdings is recognizing the accounting
can be widely
different first if you own 3% 4% 5% of a
company and have zero role in how the
companies run you might be lucky enough
to qualify what I call minority passive
Holdings with minority passive Holdings
here's what you have to show on your
income statement the dividends you
receive from those cross Holdings
dividends and on your balance sheet you
have to show what you originally
invested to get that cross holding so
I'll take you back to
1997 and talk about a company called
Soft bank it's a company still around
but in 1997 soft Bank was this young
Japanese Venture Capital firm that had
been listed still run by masan a much
younger
M and 70% of soft bank's value came from
one holding and investment they made in
Yahoo with a 50% venture capital
investment that was now worth 7
bilon so let's play it out was
classified as a minority passive
investment so if you went to soft bank's
income statement what did you see from
that
holding the dividends that yaho is
paying in 1997 which were zero you go to
the balance sheet what do you have seen
you have seen 50 million talk about a
disconnect from reality right you can
see how much you'd have left behind if
you
minority passive Investments very little
information in your financials thank God
minority passive Investments are rare
what's more common are what I called
minority active Holdings so let's play
it out let's suppose you own 20% of a
company you take some role even a small
role in how it's
run you have to use What's called the
equity approach what's the equity
approach in your income statement below
the operating income line I want to
emphasize that you have to show 20% of
the net income on net loss so now you
rather than dividends you have to show
that in your income statement and in
your balance sheet you have to take your
original investment and add 20% of the
retained earnings since like an updated
Book value not perfect but still better
than a minority passes invest and then
you get to a 60% holding I told you
accountants flip out they ask you to
count 100% consolidate both IFRS and GAP
require consolidation so when you do
your revenues
you got to count 100% of the revenues is
the subsidiary you tell the accountant
but I own only 60% the accountant says
don't worry about it to operating income
you count 100% you go to the balance
sheet cash 100% debt 100% everything at
every stage is saying but I own only
60% and finally the accountant wakes up
at the very end he says but you own only
60% you said that's what I've been
trying to tell you all this time you
don't own 40% duh
you got to take out the
40% and what do accountants do to
capture the 40% that doesn't belong to
what's the item in the balance sheet
it's called non-controlling interest or
minority interest will always be on the
liability side of the balance sheet so
before you get carried away check out
the liability side if you see an
noncontrolling or a minority interest
something is been Consolidated
somewhere might make behoove you to
figure out what it is maybe it's too
small to care
about but that's
consolidation now we've added joint
ventures to the mix there have this
there are cases where allowed partial
consolidation which means you count only
the 60% already you can see we have a
lot of cross Holdings and joint ventures
the first step in valuation is to figure
out how they've been accounted otherwise
you're going to mistreat the balance
sheet so let's first start by talking
about in an intrinsic valuation in a
perfect world how we would bring these
cross Holdings into the
mix in a perfect world here's what I
would do first I would value the parent
company with parent company financials
this would require that your company
actually have parent financials and
consolidate that's not true in in big
chunks of the world but if you have both
parent and Consolidated financials I'm
going to Value the parent company the
stand loone company without any of the
Cross Holdings then I'm going to take
each subsidiary I don't care whe it's
minority or majority value the
subsidiary is a standalone business with
own cash flows growth story discount
rate
risk and then I'm going to take the
pieces of each that you own 5% of this
seven so effectively the value that I
will attach the firm will be the parent
company Value Plus the sum of the values
of all is see the advantage of doing
this you're a chemical company with a
steel subsidiary I give the steel
company a steel company cost of capital
a steel company growth rate it allows
you to take each business and value
doesn't stand Al but to do this what do
you have to
have you have to have access to
financials for every single subsidiary
not just revenues and income but full
financials so I'll give you an example
where I had the data to do this in 2013
2014 I valued Yahoo and by the time you
got to 2014 Yahoo was a dying business
it had a search Eng that nobody searched
on and an email program that only old
people used so you value it as a
standalone business the value that you
got and I was being generous was about
7.4 billion so this is Yahoo just the
the search engine company 7.4
billion but there are two cross Holdings
of immense value one was 35% of Yahoo
Japan which was a standalone separate
company and for whatever reason the
Japanese still use yaho
yo and it was a much more prosperous
company than Yahoo the US version I
valued the and because it was a publicly
traded company I was able to get its
financials I attached a value of 20 21
billion to the equity and I took 35% of
that and the second holding was its 22%
holding of a company called
Alibaba Alibaba was still a private
business but it had just filed its
prospectus to go public which opened the
door for me because now I had the
financials for Alibaba I could value it
as a standalone company a Chinese you
know I'm not even it's not a Chinese
retail company but basically a Chinese
advertising company because it connects
buyers with Sellers and valued
separately the value that I got for
their Equity is 146 billion 22% of that
is 32 billion you add the three numbers
up and just to clean up I made sure that
if I actually had to sell these Holdings
I'd have to pay tax lities took that out
and I came up with an intrinsic value of
Yahoo that includes all three components
why was I able to do it I wouldn't have
been able to do this in 2013 because
Alibaba was still privately held I would
not have it was the F fact that they
filed a Prospectors that allowed me to
do
it so this is a rare case where I
actually value the cross Holdings why
because the cross Holdings had
financials and the other is the cross
Holdings are where the bulk of the value
of this company comes from when you're
buying Yahoo you're not buying Yahoo
this search engine you're buying a piece
of Alibaba and you're buying a piece of
Yahoo Japan and because it's so much of
the value I had to kind of fill in the
details separate you have to do three
separate valuations yeah three SE and
is only three can you imagine if
there are 15 cross Holdings how much
more work would be
involved so I'm going to talk about the
real world problems you run into the
real world problem you run into is when
you look for the data it's just not
there so let's say you're Consolidated
but it's a privately H business there's
no information there or you Holdings
another companies that privately held
and you can't get access to the full
financials and I'll tell you a story
this was in the late '90s I was working
I think on the second edition of my
investment valuation book it's valuing a
Japanese company and with Japanese
company in the 1990s you're always
teetering on the edge of disaster why
because Japanese risk free rates were so
much lower than in the rest of the world
that if you used any growth rat you used
to using in the rest of the world your
valuations blew up so I was careful I
finish up I'm patting myself on the back
I take a look at this company's balance
sheet they tell me they have
227 cross
Holdings so Leon what do I need to do
this value this one
company value 227 other companies right
there is zero chance I'm a lazy person
that I'm doing this but even if IID
wanted to I couldn't have 60 were public
I could could have got their financials
and but the other 167 were privately
owned businesses with zero information
provided on any of the operating details
so I call the investment relations
officer of this Japanese company said
look I'm valuing a company for my for a
book I'm writing it's not for an expose
could you give me some information in
your Crossing she said I
cannot he said why not she said it's
proprietary the way she said proprietary
was kind of
scary and I said that's strange what if
I bought a th000 shares in your company
and then I called you she said still be
proprietary I said I'm part owner of the
company you're refusing to tell me what
I
own she thought about it for about 10
seconds she said you have a point but
it's still
proprietor at this stage I'm banging my
head against a brick wall I get ready to
hang up the phone she said I do have
something I can tell you about these
cross Holdings maybe she's going to give
me some Revenue number or operating
income I said what she said I cannot
give you specifics but they're worth a
lot I said I'm sitting here with an
Excel spreadsheet I'm entering loot into
the cell for cross Holdings nothing is
working below it can you put some zeros
in the lot it kind of cuts to the heart
of the Cross holding culture right what
do managers do they hold up a brown
paper bank so trust me it's full of cash
I'll tell you how much cash can I look
in the back no no I'll tell you how much
that's exactly what we're letting these
companies do tell you what the value of
the Cross Holdings is why would they
ever let you look in the bag so when I
hear Emerging Market investors complain
about companies not telling them much
about cross Holdings I said there's an
easy fix to it attach a value of zero to
it you'll be amazed at how quickly the
information starts to come out from the
companies that have really valuable
cross Holdings so in the real world the
problem you often have is you don't have
the information and you got to make
approximations
so I'll give you what I do I go to a
balance sheet I see cross Holdings on
the asset side and minority interest on
the liability side they're both in Book
value
terms but rather than take the book
value and say that's all I can do if I
know what businesses your cross Holdings
are in most of the time I do I go to my
database on what the price to book
ratios are for businesses let's say you
have a chemical cross holding with a
$100 million Book value and a typical
Chemical Company trades at 1. 5 times
Book value I take the 100 million * 1.5
come with am I happy with this not at
all it's sloppy I wish I could do better
but with the information I have I take
that over Book value every single time
so do the best you can with Crossings I
wish I could tell you that there was an
easier way to do it in fact with Yahoo I
actually tried pricing the entire
company what does that require I took
each segment and I applied a multiple I
stayed with EV to say why because I'm
comparing a Japanese company a Chinese
company us company who knows what the
accounting variations are so I went up
the income statement I estimated what
multiple of revenues I would expect each
of these companies to trade at we'll
talk a little later about how how I
adjusted the multiples but basically I
have for Yahoo Japan and Alibaba much
higher multiples of revenues the higher
growth more profitable
businesses I priced those companies I
added up the pricing luckily I got a
number of very close but it doesn't have
to be it's a pricing game and I'm kind
of going back to it because I don't have
the information if I hadn't had the
information to do an intrinsic
valuation so any questions on Cross
Holdings so let's talk about what else
you might be able to I've already told
you what you can't add on you can't add
on things you've already counted in your
cash
flows so you're a hotel company you
value the company as a hotel you then
can't add the value of the hotel as real
estate onto the value that you got from
your discounted cash flow valuation so
you're looking for truly vacant assets
things you haven't counted in the 1990s
when the market was booming equity
research analyst used to take overfunded
pension PL so if a pension plan is a you
know defined benefit plan the money is
in the value the fund is increased
technically the overfunding belongs to
equity research analyst but it's a
dangerous game to play right because you
can't really extract it without killing
Labor Relations for the rest of Eternity
they would count things like that or
they would say these are unutilized
assets and you're saying what exactly is
an unutilized
asset so I'll give you an example that's
a little off the beaten the E off the
beaten path but I think it brings home
the kinds of things you'd be adding on
anybody here part of the Michael price
fund you're in the micro price fund so
this fund actually the origins of the
fund you know does anybody who in the
fund know where the fund was how the
fund got the name Michael price attached
to it go ahead sir was Michael price he
like he wanted to like who was he you
know I forgot he's a rich man obviously
the question is how did he get rich he
ran a mutual fund company in the late
90s the peak of the doom boom he sold
his mutual fund company the Japanese for
a couple of billion dollars
which made him a very very wealthy man
and and N while you notices very wealthy
people you can almost predict what's
going to happen next you get a lot of
phone calls telling you're the most
special person on the face of the Earth
they're willing to name things after
you so they asked me whether I'd go ask
Michael price for money and I said are
you kidding me I would not I wouldn't
give money to NYU why would I go ask
other people to give money to N I know
exactly how much you waste the money you
can't even fix the stupid paper rolls in
the in the in the in the
bathrooms my pet pee I told him just
leave the oldfashioned rols they don't
break they wanted to put electronic
things half of them don't work that's a
different thing so but they said can you
please please go ask him because we want
this money to start this fund so I said
okay one time
exception I was part of the team that
visited Michael and he gave the money
and the fund got started and I said I
will have no Zero official role with
this and it's been going on for 25 years
but off and on you get people who've
gone through this class go to the fund
the way the fund is structured is you
make pictures to the rest of the people
on what to buy what to sell once in a
while those pictures find their way into
my room so about 15 years ago one of the
people involved in the fund walks into
my office I never like this guy but he
walked into his office you know he said
I'm facing a conundrum I very quickly
took to my computer made sure he wasn't
watching typed in the word conundrum
turned out he was confused when I said I
like the word he said what's your
conundrum he said I'm valuing Playboy I
said I don't see a conundrum yet he said
I valued Playboy and I've come up at 240
million the stock is trading at 300
million I still don't see a conundrum
third time I slipped the word in the 5
minute
conversation don't buy the stock he said
here's my conundra there's one asset
that Playboy owns that I haven't counted
in the 240
million you know what he was talking
about it was a Playboy Manch the brand
name the bunnies they're all in the cash
flows the Playboy Mansion is one of the
most valuable pieces of property in La
at that time estimated to be worth $150
million it was owned by the
company and you could see the question
should I be counting the 150 million if
you count it Playboy looks under Val I
said technically yes but you got one big
problem right there's an 85y old in a
bathrobe hanging out in the mansion that
you can't exactly EV H hefna was still
in the
mansion He said what should I do I said
check the Actuarial
tables what are you checking for 85 year
olds who surround themselves with 27
year old Playmates this isn't going to
last very long right 5 years the rest is
going to be complete what are you going
to do you're going to take the Valu the
mantion discounted back 5 years you can
use a cost to cap for Real Estate if you
want to be
fancy I don't think he did it I don't
think they bought the pitch didn't go
through with the rest of the people on
his team I forgot all about Playboy a
few years later I opened up the wall
stre
Journal this is a new
story Playboy managed to sell the
mansion with Hugh Hefner in it I'm not
kidding this guy Darren Metropolis
bought the mansion with the condition
that he you Hefner would stay there
until he
died and they got $200 million the
minute after this happens think of what
happens to Playboy cash balance right it
increases by 200 million this is the
kind of asset we're talking about not
brand name not the stuff you've already
counted and already you can see it's
rare it's uncommon so when you see lots
of stuff added on to a DCF valuation
most of the time people are double
counted but once in a while you will get
this something you haven't counted
because you haven't counted new cash
flows but I want to bring up also while
before I finish I talked about that
hotel example let's say value a hotel as
a hotel the W histori right say a hotel
you might get 300 million for the hotel
you know how much of real estate that
the walf is sitting under this wor
probably half a
billion so here's my question for you
the DCF valuation gives you 300 million
the value of real the real estate is a
half a billion if you're an investor
which of those two numbers would you use
to decide whether to buy shares in the
company or
not the 300 million you got from your
DCF the 500 million that you got from
the real estate or something in the
middle if you were acquiring the company
the W what did you use Michael well you
would understand that it's worth 500
million but you would try to pay 300 but
let's say you you get bit up right when
would you
stop so close to but the minute you buy
it what do you have to do right
after you'd have to do what they did
with the plaza right what did they do
with the Plaza Hotel the people who
bought it turned it into Apartments
instantaneously so if you're going to do
this as an acquirer you got to carry the
suits not just how much you pay it's
what you do afterwards but if you're a
passive investor you can see the problem
here right if you pay the 500 million
that you think the real estate is worth
and the people running the hotel are
just emotionally attached to running a
hotel you're going to be stuck with the
300 million there are textile factories
in the middle of
Mumbai that are carryovers from 50 60 70
years ago that you look at the land they
sit on they were the fraction of the
value of the land but the family that
runs them is so attached to the fact
that they're a textile
family they continue so it's not an easy
thing to unlock especially corporate
governance for but you can see this Happ
and increasingly around the world I
think especially with Hotel
companies this is more the rule than the
exception I can't think of too many
Hotel companies are worth more as Hotel
companies than there are as collections
of real estate and that's a very
dangerous place to be if your hotel
company because where do you build your
next hotel where the real estate price
will appreciate the most not and this is
why marot 30 years ago said this is not
going to stand because our hotels are
being built by the real estate guys
because they're the ones driving the
decision process what did marot
do they took the real estate they spun
it off as a reate so now when you invest
in marot you get just a hotel management
company they don't own any the hotels
there's a Marriot reath that owns the
real estate which I think is far
healthier I think if you're a company
that gets so much of your value from
Real Estate and much of Asia where real
estate prices have soared I think the
best thing you can do often is separate
the real estate there was one period in
the US in the in the in the early 2000s
where real estate prices soed where
companies actually found a way to eat
their cake and have it
too what do they do that allow them to
unlock the real estate values while
continuing as businesses
can you sell the real estate and then
lease it back that's exactly what they
did they sold the real estate they
collected the high prices and because
the lease rates didn't keep up with the
value of the real estate you could sell
277 Park and lease it back and pay a
fraction so again it's the underlying
real estate that's causing the
Distortion yes um how would you go about
valuing it or like what would you do if
like there's the real estates use as
collateral then you got a loan writing
on it but the bank is not going to
complain if you want to take the real
estate and sell it you're going to pay
off the loan so no bank will ever get in
your way if you want to do that they're
going to encourage you say do it let me
get my cash out of here so you're not
going to get people stopping you from
doing it because since the value of the
real estate is so much more than the
value of the underlying property you
face more risk as a bank if it stays a
hotel than if they liquidate right I'll
predict that as real estate price have
gone up this is an issue you're going to
see more and more rise to the surface
when you're looking at these companies
right
let talk about a fourth scenario right
we gave the example here let's say
you're looking at two companies they
look exactly the same in terms of
numbers cash flows growth rate tax rate
return on Capital they all look the same
but one company is simple it's in a
single business has a very simple
holding structure you can see exactly
what they own and its accounting is
transparent what does that mean they
tell you how much money they made what
they own what they owe which is what
accounting is supposed to do Company B
has has exactly the same numbers it's in
multiple
businesses some of which you don't even
know what the business is has a very
complex holding structure special
purpose entities cross Holdings joint
ventures and opaque accounting what's
Opa accounting you read the financial
statements they claim to be in English
but you have no idea what they're saying
it's it's in this language called
legales which vaguely resembles English
but you need 16 law ERS to kind of
deconstruct it it's like watching Enigma
over and over again what's the code do I
get the code you got to go to law school
know spend 10
years simple company complex company and
I ra started the class with the question
which one would you pay more for and in
a traditional textbook the answer is
they're both worth the same because the
numbers are the same I'll tell you when
this became an issue in this class in
the late '90s there was a company called
Tao Tao was a conglomerate that grew
through acquisition had a gigantic
accounting Scandal and the accounting
Scandal was they used the debris from
acquisition accounting to hide a lot of
bad stuff what do I mean by debris from
acquisition accounting items like
Goodwill and restructuring charges
turned out they' hidden a lot of bad
stuff it all blew up the stock price
dropped 70% but that wasn't the real
story in the class the fact that GE lost
15% of its value in parallel he's saying
what's G got to do with Tao what did I
describe Tao
a conglomerate that grew through
Acquisitions what was z a conglomerate
that grew through Acquisitions you see
why investors's thinking was right I got
fooled by Tao how do I know I'm not
being fooled by
G in class and I said what do you think
about this and everybody in the class
agreed that we need to find a way to
bring complex into evaluations because
clearly it is hurt hurting what
investors are willing to pay so I said
okay that's a neat idea but to do this
you you first have to measure complexity
right you can't just say I'll know it
when I see it and second convert that
measure of complexity into something in
your valuation remember the it
proposition cash flows discount rates or
growth rate they all agree great idea
and they said how do we measure
complexity they said we don't know
that's why you're teaching the class
right I said okay I'll give it a try I
came back the next session and I have to
tell you they weren't
impressed I counted the number of pages
in the 10 q and the 10q I know it's
incredibly simplistic but if you wanted
to avoid one company on this list to
Value which one would that
be
1,26 pages to tell me what this isn't
War and Peace this is how many pages it
took them to tell me what happened last
year takes a thousand Pages tell me what
happened last year one heck of a screwed
up
company I put this up as I said they
weren't impressed they said we're not
paying at that point it was 140,000 now
it's up to 200,000 for an MBA I don't
know what the actual cost is to count
pages in a 10K we want something more
sophisticated I said I see the point
I'll be back next week came back next
week what I call my valuation
list it's a technical term all the
things that bug me when I value a
company and how much they bug me I'm
capable of converting anything into a
spreadsheet number I remember when my
daughter had to pick between colleges
she she was incredibly
indecisive so I went through a list of
all the things she said I put weights on
it Bas and came up with a weighted score
then she threw me off we visited toughs
and she walked out the 15 minutes and
I'm not going to school yet I said why
not she said there's one ply toilet
paper I said you never told me this was
high up on your list right so the
problem is it didn't work for my
daughter with complexity though I took
thought about things that have bugged me
when I value companies how much they bug
me and come up with the store
so let me give you examples of things
that have bugged me through history a
company that claims to be geographically
Diversified but doesn't tell you where
so why do you even throw in the
geographically Diversified or they tell
you where but you don't recognize any of
the parts of the world they claim to
operate
in a company's effective tax rate goes
from 30% to minus5 to 22 you know what
that tells you right there are two sets
of books and you're showing me the
reporting books the tax books are very
different so I took
the things that bother me weighted
scores came up with a weighted score
came back to class and said do you like
this more they said this is so much
better this is why would come back for
an MBA
for but I said there's one catch to come
up with this number for City group what
do I need to
do read 1,26 pages I said I'm not in the
mood to do that but each of view is
valuing a company right they could see
the train coming at them down the tracks
too late to get out of the way now they
said said yes and I said this semester
in addition to valuing a company I'd
like you to come up with a complexity
score they bitched and they more but
what choice do they have they should
have just stayed with my number of
pages but that semester we got I know I
got a complexity score for each of the I
think 250 people in the class and I'll
give you things that were interesting
that came out of that those complexity
scores there was Zero correlation
between company size and complexity my
prior were big companies complex small
companies not so not no not the case
there were small companies were
incredibly complex and much of the
complexity was by design it wasn't
accidental second they found that
Emerging Market companies were more
complex than de developed Market
companies primarily because of cross
Holdings not because of accounting
structures third they found that any
company that grew through Acquisitions
was about 40% and more complex than a
company that did not some of you are
already discovering this the hard way if
you're valuing a company that grows
through Acquisitions Acquisitions are
messy they're lumpy they're tough to
deal with and finally they found that
any company with a financing
arm was significantly more complex 50%
more so than company without what am I
talking about financing arm yeah like
Ford Motor Company Ford Ford Capital
Volkswagen Volks why because you got a
captive bank it's not a regular bank
right it's a captive Bank captive Bank
why because almost all of their
financing is for people buying Ford
cars often they're the ones who through
which you deliver the discounts to get
people to buy so it's a very strange
bank with a lot of debt and the company
says trust us there's a Chinese wall
around the bank I have no idea whether
there's actually a Chinese
wall they also found that Accounting in
general had made things more complex
over time every time accounting rule
writers add a rule it adds to the
complexity I know they're well
intentioned but it's adding to
complexity so once you measure
complexity question is where do I put it
I'll give you the choices in good times
you just ignore it the 1990s nobody
cared about complexity the com boo it's
only when things get a little dangerous
risky that you start thinking about
complexity
in the next few months you're going to
see all those hidden flaws in a paler or
one of the young tech companies come to
the surface because all you need is the
market price to go down 20% and people
start noticing it's like being the coach
of a team notice when you're winning
nobody points out the fact that your
calls are all wrong you just happened to
win because you got lucky the minute you
start losing oh my God this guy's a
terrible coach how did that happen
overnight
so in good times but in bad times you
got to find a place to put it and here
are the choices you can take your cash
flows and haircut them what is
haircutting them in a complex company
knock off 3 5 10% people call these
conservative estimates but effectively
that's what you doing I don't like it
because it's completely arbitrary the
second is you can use a higher discount
rate for complex firms and here I can
offer you a way there I told you I spent
a month on
complexity and one of the things I did I
took the S&P 500 and I split it down the
middle into 250 simpler and 250 more
complex companies subjective judgment
but I threw them into two parts and then
I computed the implied cost of equity
remember how we did the implied Equity
risk Fram for each group The Complex
companies had an implied cost of equity
about 1% higher than the simpler
companies and that extra 1% becomes an
extra so you push up the discard rate
but I'll give you my favorite way of
dealing with complexity you know what
value right whether you can earn more
than your cost of capital and when we
did that we talked about what might
cause a company to earn more than its
cost of capital which is competitive
advantages barriers entry which if you
understand what a business does you can
list for me so if I ask you what are the
competitive
advantages of
apple or what are the competitive
advantages of fizer it's a pretty simple
list to go through but if you're looking
at a company where you're not sure what
it does it makes a lot of money how the
heck can you can you tell me that they
can keep doing what they're doing if you
have no idea what they're doing in the
first place in the late '90s one of the
companies that would repeatedly show up
in this class as a company being valued
was
andron that time $70 billion market cap
company considered
Superstar this is before the accounting
scandals and all of the fiascos that
followed to a person every person who
picked andron come into my office and
say I know they're making a lot of money
but I don't know what they
do what was that WR what was what did
they
do energy Trader what the heck does that
even mean who you buying the energy from
who you selling it to why are you able
to make the
difference and why isn't other you know
so it was kind of a fuzzy business on
top of that they also had all these
special purpose entities they were
incredibly profitable but nobody had any
idea what they
did so they said I don't know what Enron
does and my response was not that there
was an accounting scan I didn't know
that I said if you don't know what they
do then don't assume they can earn more
than their cost of cap for other than a
very short time period close the gap and
if you close the gap the minute you did
that half of enron's value disappeared
andron always looked overvalued once you
closed the Gap if you're valuing a
business where you're unclear how the
company makes money it's very dangerous
to assume they can keep doing this for
the next 10 years and not well about
their cost of
capital final piece of this monthly of
complexity I decided to run a regression
I took the 100 largest market cap
companies in the US ran a regression
against return Equity baa and growth
rate which are conventional variables
we'll talk about why they show up and
you look at Price to Book later in the
class but I threw in the number of pages
in The 10K into the
regression to help me out here what's
this minus 003 telling me about price to
piure no don't Co ient doesn't tell you
that right that that's a t statistic
standard error right the coefficient
just is a function of the number of
units on your dependent variable so
large coefficients don't are not better
than small ones because it depends on
what you're multiplying by okay so if
you take that to and that was
statistically significant minus 03 what
does it mean every 100 pages in your 10K
suit finished off what
happened basically every every th page
your price your valuation goes down
let's make it 100 100 already pushes
you.3 right so lowers your Price to Book
ratio above3 so your city group and your
Price to Book ratio is 0.9 which it was
then I have a very simple proposal for
you to double your price to book what
should you do knock 300 pages off your
10K sounds incredibly factious but he's
saying simplify I am convinced that
money center Banks now face a problem
since 2008 investors have lost faith in
being able to break them up they now
every Money Center Bank CEO complains
about given their return Equity why are
they trading at Price to Book ratios
that they did before because that
complexity I mean do you really feel
comfortable when you invest in JP Morgan
that you know where they make money and
how they I
don't so what's the effects what if
Jamie diam were in here and he said what
should I do what's what's the logical
fix the fact that JP Morgan has become
this incredibly complicated beast and
nobody's quite sure what to
do and they trade as independent pieces
you could have JP Morgan Bank JP Morgan
Investment Bank JP Morgan trading I
think they' be worth more as the sum of
their pieces and I would say the same
thing about many of the money sent to
Banks and there are there's no
synergistic effect in fact I'm going to
argue that having a bank and Investment
Bank is actually hurting them because of
the rules being imposed on banking kind
of spreading over will Jamie Diamond do
this not in this lifetime he likes being
the emperor of the largest bank in the
world in the same advice would apply to
City Group bank that is in serious
trouble you say why because I think the
complexity is is is becoming a huge
obstacle to investors saying I trust
that bank and how it makes
money so at this stage what do we have
we have the cash flows we've dealt with
cash we've dealt with cross Holdings
other assets kind of dealt with
complexity now we get to the point of
subtracting our
debt then a rule is debt should include
all contractual obligations interest
bearing debt leases and when we do cost
of capital that's where we stop right
and with cost of capital I said be
restrictive in your definition of debt
don't start to bring everything into
debt because if you do you'll inflate
the debt number lower your cost of
capital so with the cost of capital the
rule is be conservative count only those
things that are interest bearing and
contractual but let's say use that you
use a come up with the cost of capital
you value the business and then you say
what should I subtract out things get
Messier and let's talk about why let's
suppose that you take the free casual
firm for a telecom company it's a
distressed Telecom
company and you come up with a billion
dollars in the value for the operating
assets let's say this this company has a
billion dollars in Book value of debt
but because it's distressed that debt is
trading at half of Book
value how much would you pay for the
equity in this company you see the
choice I'm asking right would you
subtract out the billion and Book value
in which case the equity is worth
nothing or would you subtract out the
market value debt it's one of the
trickiest questions I you know I go back
and forth on this you know the rule in
every valuation book is right what
should you subtract out market value of
debt which case you pay 500 million for
the equity
but why is the value Equity 500 million
because people think the company is
distressed if you're an acquir and you
pay the 500 million you make be making a
serious mistake because the minute you
buy the company what will happen to the
distress factor it's going to
disappear so this is one of those cases
where depending on whether you're
valuing it as a as a as a passive
investor expecting the 500 million to
reflect where the company is today or
whether you're doing it for a
liquidation valuation you're going to
use different answers if it's a passive
investor you might be able to get away
with the half a billion and hope that
time and health kind of come over and
you benefit from both but you're doing a
liquidation don't subtract other market
value of debt you subtract other book
value debt the bank is not going to take
half of what you owe them if they know
you've collected 1.2 billion so when you
do thatb traditional rule is market
value with distress companies might want
to kind of step back and we come back to
distress companies and talk more about
the valuation
one final point you've subtracted the
debt that's on the balance sheet you
brought in the
leases but then you look around and say
is there something else remember this is
your last chance to deal with any of the
things that worry you as an equity
investor and this is where pension plans
and lawsuits can come into
play I don't know whether you're
familiar with how Pension funds in the U
pension plans in the US are structured
they can either be defined contribution
plans or Define benefit PLS what's the
difference Define contribution Define
benefit Michael yeah the fine
contributions like 401K where fine
benefit is the pension which doesn't
exist too much in the last century many
US companies had defined pension plans
Disney until 2012 my son actually joined
Disney in 2011 he got lucky enough to be
grandfather then the last generation
getting a defined benefit plan
but defined benefits plans used to be
the dominant version of pension plans at
us companies he's saying so what in a
defined benefit plan I promise you
$1,000 a month after you retire then
what do I do I invest in stocks and
bonds and financial assets to make sure
I have enough money to pay so at the end
of every year these companies are
supposed to estimate what they own
liabilities and what the value of their
assets is leading a fund to be either
overfunded or underfunded overfunded
plans we talked about are plans where
the value of the assets is greater than
the present value of your liabilities
but underfunded plans have a
deficit so let's say you're investing in
a company with an underfunded plan he
saying shouldn't that be in my debt no
because underfunding is not something
you have to show on your books in the US
yet in other countries that's not true
if you're in Germany underfunding shows
up in the balance sheet here it's off
balance sheet but should that worry
you yeah you either deal with it as debt
or what's your other way of bringing in
the fact that you an underfunded
plan what does this company have to do
in future years to make the underfunding
go away it needs to set aside more so
you have to set a sinking fund that
reduces your cash flows in future years
so underfunding if it's there has to be
dealt with because it affects value
Equity the other issues I talked about
is we are the target of a lawsuit and if
you're in the US who is it
right will it affect your value depends
on whether it cuts to the heart of your
existence now in one of the worst
Acquisitions of all time about a decade
this is a tough contest win this German
company chemical company called
bear bought Monsanto and I remember
looking and say what's wrong with you
guys they gave some cocki story about
consolidating the animal feed business
that was a strategic reason but when
bear bought Monsanto they also bought
themselves a heap of trouble in what
form they were doing the GMOs so not
even it's round up basically every lawn
in the US is so green part of the reason
it's so green is because you're using
Roundup and Roundup over time has
created a whole host of cancer cases so
those those Cas were already navigating
their way through the Cod system there
was nothing on the back bance sheet yeah
but bear couldn't claim to know claim
ignorance of this everybody knew this
but I'm sure there's a banker who came
in and did the cash flows you know
discount back came up with the value of
the firm subtract Deb so this looks like
a
bargain and right after bear bought
Monsanto what happens a bargain it
becomes a
nightmare if you have lawsuits hanging
over your head this is your last chance
to deal with them there might only be a
5% chance you could lose the lawsuit but
if it's going to cost you 2 billion you
take the expected value are there any
law students in this
class okay my corpor oh there here's a
niche business for you in investing
right take pick companies that are
targeting lawsuit because the market has
zero idea how to deal with these
companies I saw this with Merk and voo
right you go from ecstasy to Agony to
ecstasy to Agony based on whatever
thew yeah because I work for the law F
yeah and I think that's there's Market
here there's an entire group of
companies like buer where you can argue
that if you can bring in because this is
nothing to do with Finance I have no
idea how the legal system works with the
appeals process what you end up paying
BR that could be a comparative edge
around which you invest is picking
companies in the heart of the storm and
saying I am in better position to assess
what this will play out as but that's
your last job let's do one final thing
and I'll set up at least and this will
be for the next class as I said over the
last few decades increasingly us
companies have turned to using equity
and there's good reasons for right what
are the re what are some of the reasons
why a company might Grant Equity to its
employees yeah go ahead they don't have
to use cash one is your cash for this
allows you what else them invested you
able there's an incentive thing now they
want to do want at least in theory think
like shareholders so there are good
reasons for using Equity so I no problem
with it but it does create a cost don't
tell me it's Costless and free because
that makes no sense and there two forms
that Equity compensation get take one is
in the 1990s 90% of the equity
compensation the US took the form of
options today 90% of take the form of
restricted stock we'll talk about what
caused that shift it was an accounting
change in how options were expensed that
made the difference but next class we're
going to talk about how employee
compensation affects cash flows and
value and how to bring it into the
process so I will see you on Wednesday
ni
right
write WR the
wrong
yeah it's I guess from
and I'd be
interested yeah literally there's gonna
be
multip differental identities
that's like kind of the only thing they
have still run away
disappear it's more on the client side
it's like it's like
never that was on the panel I
think yeah um last year Tech MBA has
that I hear it's better than I'll hear
back this
week very demanding but it's not as
risky
as I
mean I'd
say like you don't even need
a actually have of
somebody I could send you an email of
this
guy we
me we can turn a let's negotiate but um
I need to
refer can I get the referral Bon